[Music]
hello from Hong Kong a world city like
no other extends the warmest welcome to
you be inspired by an invitation to the
world from Hong Kong's leader John Lee
he's fronting a multi-million dollar
campaign to put the city back on the map
as a tourism and finance Hub after a
tumultuous few years
months of anti-government Street
protests in 2019 led to a Crackdown on
descent and the introduction of a
controversial National Security Law
the government then imposed some of the
world's strictest covid-19 rules during
the pandemic the result a public Exodus
local businesses have taken a beating
and the city recorded its biggest
population drop in 2022
Hong Kong's economy shranked three and a
half percent last year that's the third
contraction in the last four years and
that's adding to local concerns that the
city is lagging behind rival Asian
Financial Centers such as Singapore
the government says it's time for a
turnaround it's handing out hundreds of
thousands of free flights and more than
a million spending vouchers and
scrapping all remaining covid-19 border
restrictions with the Chinese mainland
you can see the streets are getting a
bit busier but I think there are still a
lot of hidden Warriors business
confidence still seems volatile and it's
hard for people to feel they have enough
money to save we have to wait and see
but we'll just try to stay positive and
just see how things go
one sector that can't wait much longer
is the tourism industry local travel
agents have been organizing networking
events to get back on track Hong Kong
received 56 million visitors in 2019 in
2021 a rival slumped to 90 000. we've
done local tours with governments
government support but we've been losing
money left right center and we hope to
stop the bleeding this year Hong Kong is
one of the world's most beautiful cities
Hong Kong is a is a stand-up kid a
comeback kid it will always come back
John Lee is kick-starting that comeback
campaign with a trip to the Middle East
on Saturday he's leading a business
delegation to Saudi Arabia and the
United Arab Emirates he says it's time
to share the great stories of Hong Kong
and make sure the world knows the city
is finally open for business again
Richard Kimber Al Jazeera in Hong Kong